[Music]  you will never learn Vulcan your tongue  is too human great unifiers are few and  far between often such leaders will need  a profound cause  what am I looking at object of unknown  origin we've come all this way captain  it would be irresponsible to leave  whatever that is unknown I sense the  coming of death I sense it coming now  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  captain what signatures detective  context our feet command we have engaged  the Klingons  we target its neck cut off its head  dafif doesn't find it but we tattoo  what have you done out there on the edge  of Federation space I'm trying to save  you I'm trying to save all of you  [Music]  [Music]  you